el aplauso no habla de tulipanes ni de
margaritas se refiere a las flores de la
marihuana estamos en la feria Plaza
abierta en el centro de Asunción es un
oasis de permisividad en uno de los
países más conservadores de Sudamérica
mucho más abierto anteriormente este
tipo de encuentro no se puede hacer con
tanta tranquilidad como hoy en día
Aquí está permitido fumar Cannabis y
vender aceite pero es mucho más que una
feria es una demanda política que acá
estamos viendo toda esta gente que
quiere comprar quiere comprar legal
quiere comprar algo rico quiere gastar
dinero quiere pagar impuestos quiere
generar mano de obra Paraguay es el
mayor productor de marihuana de América
del Sur Juan Carlos critica la
experiencia de Uruguay por su escaso
desarrollo comercial y aboga por un
modelo paraguayo que potencia en la
producción legalizada de Pequeños
campesinos a través de cooperativas
estamos en el congreso tenemos un
proyecto de ley en marcha y esto es a
una semana de cortar un poco con la
hipocresía de que en este país tan
rodeado en algo política y tanta
historia nunca se hable de marihuana de
una elección Esperanza Martínez fue
ministra de salud y defiende el uso
medicinal del Cannabis su partido
presentado un proyecto de ley en el
senado que pretende arrebatar el control
del cultivo a las grandes corporaciones
que producen medicamentos a base de
cannabis y al mismo tiempo luchar contra
el narcotráfico
Ese es el objetivo no solamente combatir
el negocio transnacional ilícito y toda
la violencia que viene detrás sino
también hacer una reconversión económica
de los pequeños productores que hoy
están haciendo en la clandestinidad Sin
embargo un sector del partido Colorado
que gobierna el país considera que la
legalización debe ser una estrategia
global y no local que da por ver si el
nuevo congreso aprobará una ley que
divide a la sociedad paraguaya